so we don't yet know whether Ron
DeSantis the Republican Florida Governor
is going to enter the race and challenge
Donald Trump's seemingly uh unchangeable
path to the Republican nomination one
guy we know is running is Vivek
ramaswami and I'm going to play for you
we're not going to spend a lot of time
on this this is basically just almost
satire at this point
Vivek ramaswami was interviewed on Fox
News
and he now is jumping into the tears in
my eyes stories
I don't understand what the obsession is
with with people crying for these
Republicans but you may know that Trump
is known for telling stories most of
which we believe are made up of people
coming to him crying with tears in their
eyes and Eric Trump sometimes will jump
into it Donald Trump will sometimes tell
these stories and the way these stories
go is you know Eric Trump will say
listen I boarded a JetBlue flight the
other day I fly commercial all the time
and as I boarded everybody stood up and
cheered and a couple of guys came up to
me and they were crying and they were
saying you've been treated so unfairly
we've got your dad's back and then
usually we listen to that story and we
go nobody was doing that nobody nobody
burst into tears on a JetBlue flight
over uh Eric Trump just being there so
anyway it's the with tears in my eye
stories Vivek ramaswami now claims
that at one of his events a guy came in
wearing a Maga shirt the guy went up to
ask a question started crying and then
abandoned supporting Trump and decided
to support Vivek ramaswamy our friend
Aaron rupar tweeted filed this under
things that didn't happen take a listen
to this one of the people who actually
stood up at that same event was somebody
who walked in with in with Trump shirt
broke down in tears as he asked the
question thinking about the country and
what we were doing for his children said
he was switching over to vote for me I'm
absolutely running for the presidency
could that possibly be true like it Matt
it also to honestly
there's nothing wrong with crying there
is nothing wrong with crying and if
anything we maybe have a lot of people
who have been sort of culturally
conditioned not to express emotion so
this is not about this there's nothing
wrong with crying but what what sort of
circumstances would lead to you being a
trump supporter but you go out I'm going
to go to vivex event but I'm going to
wear my Maga shirt and then when they do
questions you say even though I'm a
trump supporter I'm going to ask a
question and then in the course of
asking the question you're so overcome
with emotion for how wonderful what
Vivek is proposing is a guy who's
polling what three percent that you
break down in tears and say I'm
abandoning my support for Trump and now
I support you while crying it's either
an obvious lie or a sign of
extraordinary emotional instability
nothing wrong with crying that scenario
strikes me as Bonkers totally and
completely Bonkers so do we believe this
I don't believe it I don't believe it
you tell me whether you think that story
could even possibly be true